the Joe Rogan experience and that's why
it's important that Bernie gets in
that's why it's important that he
overcomes their cheating and I just want
Burt you talk about schizophrenic like
Bernie has a schizophrenic strategy like
people are upset that I critique his
strategy
I went Bertie to be stronger I want him
to win and I want him to so like he Kyle
come on give a speech where he says I'm
running against the Democrat has
establishment and people go crazy right
because we know that's the problem and
then he'll do a video where he endorses
the DNC like hey give us money we got he
listed a video with all the Democratic
candidates talking about unity and you
every campaign had to pay one hundred
and seventy thousand dollars to the DNC
to be included in that video why because
the DNC is bankrupt why because no one's
donating to it and so they have to
extort money out of their own candidate
saying if you don't give us a hundred
seventy thousand dollars each to do this
unity video we won't have any money to
help you once you win the nomination so
they all pointed up and they're all in
it and Bernie's in a unity video where
he's supposed to be speaking against the
millionaires and billionaires there's
two billionaires in the [ __ ] video
Tom Steyer and Bloomberg we got to come
together with boo billionaires to oppose
no they are the [ __ ] problem is the
problem he's not he's the guy who
instituted stop-and-frisk he's the guy
who says New York needs more
billionaires those are the [ __ ] guys
who are the problem and if Bernie would
just got stopped you know playing
footsie with them in a sense you know
and just bash them I think it wouldn't
even be close they would say he's got it
like Barack Obama he's got to over win
because they're gonna cheat him so he
has to over win you know and I tell you
what if he picked of tulsi gabbard as
his vice president he would crush Donald
Trump because there are a lot of
right-wingers and there's a lot of
independence there's a lot of anti-war
people who are upset with the Republican
Party a lot of independents libertarians
were set and they like her because she's
a and all the things that you like about
her she's young she doesn't fly off the
hip and she's proven herself as a
patriot all that stuff what do you think
they're doing who do you think they're
leaning towards for the nominee do you
think they want Warren
oh the establishment yes yeah then whoa
devil that's why the DNC and the media
and Elizabeth Warren's campaign
coordinated on this latest sexist hit on
Bernie Sanders but it's not working
I don't think so I think it's backfire
it's it should backfire it's just it's
amazing that the the Pocahontas stuff
that she's gotten as far as she has is
with lying about being Native American
and using it to get a job and the way
she lies about it I mean she's such a
bet again she's also a bad liar
like when Megan McCain can twist you at
a pretzel that's not good you know when
she went on some podcast with these
black guys I don't even ever see that
video where she's being interviewed by
three black guys and they just yeah they
just tear her to shreds
was that Charlemagne is that on The
Breakfast Club I think maybe I don't
know your name I don't know anything
Charlemagne sharp as [ __ ] I think he
went after her for the whole native yeah
thing and she was just basically saying
what's well it's a family worry that we
he nailed it was it was easy you know it
was like you got you talking to Barry
Weiss questions Carrie what is toady
mean Charlamagne tha God calls Elizabeth
Warren the original Rachel Dolezal
that's right yes that's right yeah
that's what he did yes yes yes yeah yeah
that is a that's a hilarious thing to
say the original originals though well
she used it to get a job I mean she
really did and she didn't give any of
that money back I mean didn't she get a
job at Harvard because of that where she
claimed she did it she claims she did
but it was on her application yeah she
was Native American reason why yeah and
she's just saying this because our
family but she was saying she's Native
American like that's the whole thing
you're a hot a hundred percent that I
don't know what she was right
I know it's it's really come back to
bite her in the ass I know I bet you
enough not enough she still bouncing
around I think that's how a liar like
she's a she's a person that makes up a
past she's created a fake pass and she
did it back when there was no DNA test
available so you can get away with being
Native American it makes you look like
you're well first of all you're kind of
cool right everybody like you ever see
that movie Vision Quest
no great movies Matthew Modine his
buddy's a fake Indian his buddy lied
about being Native American he had a
mohawk and everything he was playing up
the Native American thing because people
want to be Native American it's a cool
thing yeah you know they're they've
thought to be more spiritual yeah more
deep and interesting and and it's
certainly more oppressed so if you say
the if she says she's Native American no
look at this Native American woman I
made it all the way to be President it's
exactly yeah meanwhile she's like what
like 1 mm Native American is that what
it was some ridiculous ridiculously
small numbers right so she didn't when
she got her DNA test Trump said that she
if she was Native American that he would
give a million dollars to charity give
her a million dollars some of that and
since she was like well time to pay up
like what did you look at the numbers
yes she did yes she did
Joe everything you're saying right now
is sexist I hope you know that
[ __ ] yeah everything you're saying is
saying mmm must be right I'm talking
about a woman what do people you know
what I you know you talk about how you
feel bad about the New York Times that
being yes because I know I know that
feeling you wanted somebody to be what
what are the other news people like at
MSNBC and say what did they think when
they see Tucker Carlson kicking their
ass doing war coverage isn't that
[ __ ] amazing the Tucker Carlson thing
was interesting right because that
amazing he seems at least partially
independent like Hawaii's he allowed to
tell the truth about war at Fox News I
don't [ __ ] get that they're not
allowed to tell the truth about war at
CNN or MSNBC well Shepard Smith was
allowed to tell the truth - but he's
sorry truth but he was again - why the
[ __ ] out here yeah
again there's a lots of truths he didn't
tell also so that's why did you see
bombshell no what is this that's the
movie with the Roger Ailes movie oh I
started watching that oh man that guy
who's the actor that from Australia
what's his name Oh whoever the guy is
he's fantastic in bomb what business
that John Lithgow and bombshell though
if you're thinking - the Dick Cheney
movie I'm thinking of a series there's a
series about Roger Ailes and Fox News oh
and no this is a movie
this is a new Charlize that all oh
really
yeah well she plays megyn kelly oh
really yeah yeah
so she book and playing someone else
attractive ni WRC is a non-profit
working to protect Native women from
violence more than half on
women have experienced sexual violence
in the majority of violent crimes
against Native Americans are perpetrated
by non-natives send them your one
million dollar check real Donald Trump
so she was saying that because she's
Native American she tested like a trace
amount like it really it's probably like
she blew a Native American guy in
college well when it by the way real
Donald Trump I remember saying on 7/5
you give me 1 million dollars for
charity if I choice my DNA showed Native
American ancestry I remember and here's
the verdict warrant tests were worn
reveals test confirming ancestry yeah
but it's such an insanely small amount
oh god I am 1.6 percent African I am 200
times more Native American that's real
yeah lol so imagine I mean I thought
that when she said she got fired from
teaching and then the video came out
said she quit I thought that would be
the end that should be the end - I got
called for talking about that oh you are
such sister I had a Clinton advisor come
at me a Bill Clinton advisor
that's hilarious advisers should all
shut the few thing up you would think
you are so lucky you're not in jail you
only flew 26 times with Jeffrey Epstein
it's not a lot of times he was a good
guy he had a nice jet we flew around we
saw the sky we looked at things we had a
couple drinks you do a good Clint it's
all right
[Applause]